this episode of real science is brought
to you by curiosity stream sign up today
at curiosity stream comm slash real
science and get free access to watch
nebula calm China is battling a new and
rapidly spreading respiratory virus
tonight growing concern about a
mysterious deadly virus says thousands
of travelers from China are screened at
American airports the World Health
Organization is holding an emergency
meeting tomorrow to talk about this
virus as more and more people get sick
the virus is now killed more than a
hundred people in China and new cases
have been confirmed around the world the
war on coronavirus is all over the news
cycle and for good reason thousands of
people have been infected and hundreds
have died the exact numbers increasing
every day the World Health Organization
just declared a state of emergency and
they say that the global risk is now
high the outbreak started in Wuhan China
has begun to spread to several other
countries this particular strain of
coronavirus has never been seen before
by scientists a new strain called the
2019 novel coronavirus corona viruses
are viruses that usually only infect
animals and rarely make the jump to
humans but if they do it's bad corona
viruses are large viruses enveloped in
lipids that contain single-stranded RNA
like all viruses they infect a host cell
to access the machinery that the host
cell normally uses to replicate its own
DNA and then hijacks that machinery in
order to reproduce itself forcing the
host to manufacture new viruses viruses
can't reproduce by themselves without a
host and so they are not considered to
be living creatures they are basically
just packages of nucleic acid and
protein but because viruses contain
nucleic acid genomes just like all cell
based life they too have genetic
variation and can evolve into new forms
they are not really living but too
creepy to be considered inanimate either
they exist somewhere in between symptoms
of the viral illness occur as a result
of cell damage and the associated
immune response the Wuhan coronavirus
usually gives its victims an upper
respiratory tract illness and for those
with a weakened immune system the
elderly and the very young it can lead
to deadly pneumonia coronaviruses are
Zuo notic diseases meaning they are
transmitted from animals to people some
of the most devastating virus outbreaks
originated in bats including Ebola MERS
and SARS however direct transmission
from bats to humans is rare the jump
from animals to humans usually occurs
through an intermediate animal reservoir
with other virus epidemics like SARS the
animal intermediates were civets which
were being sold in wet markets in China
and the wet markets where the civets
were being sold are places that are
poorly regulated where people in live
and dead wild animals like porcupines
crocodiles snakes and more are in close
contact in these places it is all too
easy for a virus to make an interspecies
jump in the case of the Wuhan virus
scientists now think that the
intermediary species could be the
Chinese cobra due to genetic similarity
between the virus genome and the snakes
an outbreak like this is obviously
alarming but at what point does it
become uncontrollable how does a disease
become a pandemic and how can it be
stopped a pandemic is when a disease
spreads across a wide geographical area
and affects many people and if it
infects people quickly a pandemic can
reach nearly every corner of the globe
the Wuhan coronavirus has already made
the jump from an animal host into human
hosts and scientists are now reporting
that it can definitely spread between
people - and it's spread is accelerating
so there is good reason that the world
is worried that this could be a global
disaster to understand the likelihood of
that happening let's look back on the
history of past outbreaks to see the
other vectors that allow a virus to
wreak havoc across the globe when you
think about the major death tolls of the
20th century you probably imagine a big
spike like this for World War 1 and
another for World War 2 but in between
these two wars was another huge surge in
deaths this one caused by the most
severe pandemic in recent history and
perhaps of all time
the 1918 influenza pandemic also known
as the Spanish flu
500 million people or one third of the
world's population became infected with
this virus and an estimated 50 to a
hundred million people worldwide died
because of it the pandemic lasted just
15 months but killed more people in a
year than AIDS has killed in 40 and more
than the bubonic plague killed in a
century and weirdly it was very
effective at killing young in otherwise
healthy people no one knows exactly
where the virus started and researchers
are still trying to figure out exactly
why it was so devastating especially to
young people but what is known however
is that it ticked the two boxes of what
makes a truly catastrophic pandemic it
spread easily and it killed easily part
of the reason for this had to do with
the particular state of the world at the
time crowded conditions and the movement
of troops definitely played a role in
the spread of the disease health care
workers were also spread thin because of
the war and there were limited ways to
treat a viral infection at the time the
world was still a long way from the
antiviral medications and vaccines that
can now help to stem the spread of a
virus and promote a quicker recovery so
today with better living conditions
standards of Hygiene and modern medicine
this level of devastation can be avoided
right well hopefully but not necessarily
while different conditions exist today
which helped make a pandemic less likely
in some ways other things make the risk
even higher as the world's population
grows there is a greater possibility
someone will encounter a virus that will
spread to others and as people are
traveling greater distances today than
ever before and in larger numbers
viruses are able to spread more rapidly
this factor in particular is what has
everyone in such a panic 17 years ago
the world contended with exactly these
threats and a similar virus outbreak
also in China SARS SARS stands for
severe acute respiratory syndrome and is
a viral respiratory illness also caused
by a corona virus called SARS associated
Korean
virus in 2003 over the course of a few
months the illness spread to more than
two dozen countries it was characterized
by high fever and in most cases led to
pneumonia SARS spread by close
person-to-person contact through
respiratory droplets like a cougher
sneeze a total of 8090 eight people
worldwide became sick with SARS during
the 2003 outbreak and of these 774 died
it proved difficult to contain made
worse by several mistakes and bad
choices by the Chinese government
showing the world that factors beyond
just the science of the virus determine
how bad an epidemic will be when SARS
first sprung up the Chinese government
withheld information about the epidemic
from the public and vastly underreported
the number of people that had been
infected they severely downplayed the
risks and took several months to
establish travel restrictions with
little to no information being reported
from official Chinese outlets people had
to rely on rumors and access to foreign
news many credit the severity of this
outbreak to the government's deception
and inaction if there had been prompt
and accurate reporting of the full facts
so that others could have taken
preventative measures fewer people may
have died but even with these
unfortunate circumstances SARS was
eventually contained and a total global
disaster was averted once enough
quarantines travel bans and treatment
was in place the question many are
asking now is has China learned it's
lesson enough to mitigate the damage
this time around with the Wuhan virus
China is claiming to crack down on
withholding information a central
political and legal affairs Commission
account said anyone who deliberately
delays and hides the reporting of virus
cases out of his or her own
self-interest
will be nailed on the pillar of shame
for eternity the World Health
Organization's director-general also
praised China's quick response this time
around but some experts suspect that the
true number of people infected with the
virus is still higher than is being
publicly reported but the Chinese
government does seem to be taking it
seriously
mandating that face masks be worn in
public places in some areas and imposing
strict travel bans in several Chinese
cities attempting to quarantine millions
of people urban buses Subway's ferries
and long-distance passenger transport
have been suspended in Wuhan passenger
cars however have not been blocked from
leaving the city so how effective a band
like this can be is not fully certain
but even with these actions from the
Chinese government they are only
reactive measures some reports say that
five million people left the city of
Wuhan before the ban was imposed once
the virus is out in the world it is very
hard to stop more cases are popping up
each day in different countries around
the world and very unfortunately
scientists are now reporting that the
virus can be spread in its incubation
period before symptoms appear someone
may have no idea that they have the
virus spreading it far and wide before
they even feel sick all of the action
being taken now is trying to close the
Pandora's box that has already been
opened we can only hope that the
measures being taken will be enough to
keep this from going from bad to worse
in light of epidemics like this or SARS
ultimately what China needs to do is
some soul-searching about the state of
the wild animal trade in the country On
January 22nd authorities in Wuhan banned
the trade of live animals at the wet
markets but this is too little too late
and in all likelihood not permanent the
death toll is rising as it did with SARS
and in both cases it all started with
the poor regulation and trade of wild
animals whether or not this will become
a global pandemic is ultimately in the
hands of the Chinese government and
public health officials as some experts
have said one nation's weak response
could endanger the world's public health
security
many say that a global pandemic is the
biggest single threat other than a
nuclear war to the health and economy of
the entire world as epidemics like the
corona virus or Ebola seem to crop up
every few years understanding them is of
the utmost importance you can learn more
about the spread of diseases in the
impact that they have by watching
viruses destruction and creation on
curiosity stream curiosity stream is a
streaming platform that has thousands of
high quality high budget documentaries
in viruses destruction and creation
doctors virologists and scientists
examine the spread of the Zika virus
what effect the disease may have on
large populations and possible next
steps to stop the illness things that
are relevant to all virus outbreaks and
to make it even better
your curiosity stream subscription now
also comes with a subscription to nebula
the streaming platform made by the best
educational content creators like
Wendover productions Thomas Frank
minutephysics and our other channel real
engineering nebula is a place that
allows creators like us to make exciting
and original content without worrying
about the YouTube algorithm or D
monetization there are new episodes
being added all the time like real
engineering snoo episode of the
logistics of d-day series which tracks
the strategy of clearing a path through
the Defense Forces for the Allied troops
on d-day so if you sign up using the
link below you'll get access to all of
curiosity stream and olive nebula for
just $19.99 a year and be supporting a
community of creators that love making
new and exciting content
[Music]
you